there is a man that I love and that man
is not Marcia it's MP but that man
doesn't even notice me
[Music]
it's time to put on the big gloves no
more mr. nice hoodie pie
[Music]
okay bros in this episode we're going to
kill everyone everyone but senpai here
we go there are some waves that we
haven't done it before
one is ass ants you will all pay yeah
let's get [ __ ] by my bone this is what
you will of thing come on guys let's
play where are you guys running [ __ ] oh
oh yes yeah where did she get audacious
oh my god just spaghetti wacky waving
inflatable arm-flailing tube-man yes
ants for not giving me grade hey ya
[ __ ] [ __ ] does anyone want a toast
shut up
say your last prayer bye bye [ __ ]
[Music]
you on a toast
please calm down a little bit there's
another mode to [ __ ] people over with
[ __ ] yes
excuse me but have you ever tried anal
fisting what are you looking at
Oh Oh [ __ ] went to space
[Music]
oh [ __ ] look at that let's take a
picture of her panties oh that's good
saved excuse me today you have a man of
you to talk about your Lord and Savior
there oh I got you buddy there it is I
saved you oh my god um you're just
finished for the rest of your life but
it will be okay you're in safe hands now
just [ __ ] kidding you're dead to me
giraffe son of a [ __ ] oh that got a
little intense didn't it let's let's
have a nice cup of tea and think about
what we did maybe the best way to get to
senpai it's not to brutally murder
everyone maybe we should just talk to
him [ __ ] that I got a last move let's
move epic enough to make senpai notices
[Music]
they get sempai he's so beautiful
this is said I am going to talk to him I
love him he's so handsome I know what a
tragedy
they're all dead baby pity fear fear oh
it's such a hard work
now that should do the trick oh oh oh it
worked yes at last oh I've tried for 84
years to summon this team
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh oh [ __ ] it's so late I got to go back
to supper mom's gonna be super pissed if
I'm not back home in time
[Music]
[Applause]
all right breast
there was another update of yandere
simulator I love this game
let me know weed for you one more
updates I would love to give it to you
not liver like we enjoy watching I
really appreciate it
I'm so sick of saying it but it's just
to like that's all you got to do now
thank you and stay awesome oh [ __ ] the
guys seem some great ass
all right if only stuff I would
appreciate dad a s daddy daddy daddy
daddy